what happened with the top first one  percent of the country their income went  up roughly 80% bottom every part of the  country no well reducing meat on weight  every one years from 1980 to 1990 like  the lowest income no the facts are the  facts Rachel the lowest income people  have the biggest movies please please  ready go hey you stop I'll start already  wait a minute  [Applause]  80% the median wage in the country over  10 years went up 3% that means for the  best people were best off in the country  it was the matterhorn and for everybody  else in the country it was like the  helots know if you're rich you know I  mean if you were anybody else much  sucked  [Applause]